[Music]
hello and
welcome to the south american segment of
the peabody museum's
fiesta latina survey of the national
birds
of latin american countries let's maybe
begin
with the this big bird here
this actually is an immature andean
condor condor andino a
huge bird the size of the california
condor
with a three meter wingspan and this is
a baby because it takes them eight years
to achieve their adulthood and the
specimens we have here
are immature this bird
amazingly was selected as a national
bird for four different
by four different countries in south
america colombia ecuador
bolivia and chile and this is the bird
that to everybody
symbolizes the andes and
it's a majestic glider and
relies on carrion so it spends most of
the time
searching for dead guanaco or some other
llama or they can sometimes descend to
the coast and in chile
are known to eat things like
beached whales or birthing seals
and this bird can reach about
15 kilograms in body weight and in this
case females
are slightly smaller than males
we have here a
very bizarre looking bird named hawazin
in this is a national bird of guyana
where it's called kanji
pheasant because it looked
to some early explorers like
chicken-like bird
but in fact it's a bird with a
distinct lineage of really not very
clear
relationships there is not really
anything closely related to it surviving
today
it's a south american bird that lives in
swamps and along rivers
and has two bizarre
properties features one is that the
chicks
after they leave the nest they can
clamber around and they have
three fingers in their wings and
later this disappears okay so here we
have a
hoaxin adult and in this case
the three fingers of the babies are no
longer here they get reabsorbed and
the wing is the wing bones fuse and the
other feature
that uh hohatsun is famous for is the
fact that they
eat leaves and they have a foregut with
microbes that helped them digest the
plants
the leaves and they spent a lot of time
digesting like cows this is kind of an
equivalent to
what ruminants do and now let's look at
the national bird of peru
this is the gallito de rolas rocas or
the
[ __ ] of the rock here we have a male
this is a bird that is still pretty
common in
most of the indian countries not only
peru
in the cloud forest and you can actually
arrange a visit to one of the lakes
these are the
places where they display you can see
that this
crest here is a kind of flattened
on the sides two layers of feathers
folding over the bill
it's only found in males females are
rubber brown
and the name gagito de las rocas
maybe refers to the fact that they spent
the nest in little caves and
attached their mud nest to a rocky wall
so then let's look at the bird
chosen by the country of uh suriname
this is in english great kiskady
but in most countries the bird gets the
name
onomatopeia related to its song it's a
type of
tyrant flycatcher and the
the song to the english speaker sounds
like kiskady
but to a person in suriname it's greek
or hate tb if you are a dutch inhabitant
of suriname
they also occur in the united states in
southernmost texas
and they go all the way to northern
argentina so it's a pretty widely
distributed
bird but very charismatic found in
cities and
can actually easily be seen throughout
south america
so now let's look at the national bird
of brazil
sabia laranjera as it's called in
portuguese and in english
rufo's bellied thrash or robin
same as the north american robin these
are
birds common throughout suburban
rural different habitats that are
altered by humans
and it's one of the most common birds in
this
lower southern cone of south america in
uruguay paraguay argentina
and parts of southeastern brazil this
bird
maybe looks not the most colorful but
has a fantastic song and this is
same with with the costa rican
equivalent
was chosen for the song and for its
commonness in human inhabited
habitats then this colorful
bird here is to a north american
bird watcher it's an oriole but this
particular one is called tropial
and in venezuela where it's a national
bird
uh they call it turpial venasulano or
guajiro
because it's found in uh original
wahira among others uh it's uh
also found in jason colombia and it's
one of the largest
species of orioles and it's a bizarre
species indicating the reason
for that is that doesn't build a typical
hanging
hammock type nest but it actually usurps
takes over nests from other species it
has to be a covered nest so it could be
another oreo or cassik or even could be
a stick nest of some
fornarid then
let's look at the bird chosen by
paraguay as a national bird
this is actually here's the right
species but i only have a
immature male so this one here
you can see that still has a lot of kind
of greenish
gray feathers but already developing its
bare throat in english
it's called bare throated bell bird
and this bird here i'm holding is a
white bell bird as related species but
you cannot just imagine that this one
would look like this pure white
and just have a brilliantly bluish green
bare throat and the name uh
in paraguay where it's a national bird
it's called
gura kampana or gurapong
pong is onomatopeia this is
the birth is most famous for its loud
song it's one of the loudest
bird vocalizations and it does sound a
bit like a
pong or like an anvil hit with a hammer
very loud and usually from the forest
canopy
then let's look at the national bird of
uruguay
te rotero or it's called southern
lapwing in english
it has a very thin little crest
has very interestingly spurs
in the wings you can maybe just barely
see a little orange
spur let me see oh here we go and these
could be used
in nest defense uh when they chase away
a fox or
and the bird is very charismatic loud uh
attacks
an intruder to his territory especially
when the chicks
or eggs are around
so in adjacent brazil it's also
onomatopoeically called quero quero so
terotero queroquero
and the species now expands and goes
pretty far north
reaching central america and it takes
advantage actually from human
disturbance and clearing of the forest
now we're switching
here's the last example and this one is
a national bird of argentina
at this brown bird is
called either ornero or alfon alonsito
or casarita and the fame for this bird
is
is their nest so here if you can maybe
zoom in at this
fortress of mud these nests are part of
the landscape
and a pair of these in a sense that they
are found on buildings on telephone
poles
it's a really a common sight in
argentina
just in brazil paraguay uruguay
the nest is made by two of these birds
by a pair
and they uh somebody calculated to use
like 3 000 bigfools of mud and
this is mud mixed with plant material so
it's like adobe
very durable and only members of this
one group of birds genus furnarios built
this
big five kilogram type fortresses